my name is Rachel hilly and I am a
senior from Plymouth Michigan I am
studying English and organizational
communication it is my honor and
privilege to introduce our speaker this
evening Barry Straus is the Brice and
Edith M Baumer professor of humanistic
studies and chairman of the Department
of History at Cornell University where
he also teaches in the classics
department dr. Strauss earned his MA and
PhD at Yale University a recipient of
the Lucio Coletti journalism prize for
literature
he received the Clark Award for
Excellence in teaching from Cornell's
College of Arts and Sciences he has
received fellowships from numerous
institutions including the National
Endowment for the Humanities the Korea
Foundation and the American Academy in
Rome in recognition of his scholarship
he was named an honorary citizen of
Salamis Greece he is the author of
numerous books including the Battle of
Salamis the naval encounter that saved
Greece masters of command Alexander
Hannibal Caesar and the genius of
leadership and the death of Caesar the
story of history's most famous
assassination please join me in
welcoming dr. Barry Strauss
Thank You Rachael for that very kind
introduction thank you everyone for
coming tonight it's a great pleasure and
honor to be here at Hillsdale so I'm
going to speak to you about someone who
led one of the most interesting lies of
the ancient world
a man who beast rode the narrow world
like a colossus Julius Caesar he
conquered Gaul adding France Belgium
much of the Netherlands parts of Germany
and for a period England to the Roman
Empire he took on the Senate and most of
the Roman army and won a civil war that
left him as the dictator for life of
Rome a position that had never existed
before and left many of his fellow
citizens wondering whether he wanted
nothing less than to be king but my
subject tonight is not so much Caesars
life as his death this is less a
biography than a mor tog Rafi or to use
the proper Greek a Thanet ography the
assassination of Julius Caesar on the
Ides of March March 15 44 BC perhaps the
most famous assassination in history and
the question that I'm going to be asking
is what do we know about this
assassination and can we trust the
sources well by some lights this is the
best documented single event in all of
greco-roman history at least pagan
history we have more sources and more
information about it than probably any
other single event that's the good news
the bad news is that very few of these
sources are contemporary sources and
none of the sources ladies and gentlemen
absolutely none of them is objective
there's a good reason for that and
that's because the ancients scorned
objectivity
didn't believe in objectivity in the
sense that we do they believed in
accuracy and in truth but they thought
that the way to reach truth and the way
to accuracy was not by being objective
but by telling their audience what they
needed to hear what was most important
for them to hear they felt it was their
job to shape and improve the raw data to
reach the truth part of the reason for
this is that their audience was largely
not readers rather their audience was
listeners ancient literature by and
large was meant to be heard rather than
read and it's both a blessing and a
curse that our sources of information
for the assassination of Caesar includes
some of the most talented prose writers
of antiquity it makes their accounts
very seductive but it also makes their
accounts very dangerous all of this
might be the cause for despair and
perhaps if I were a modern historian
used to the luxury of archives and and
the plethora of information I would
despair but luckily I'm a classicist I
don't expect to have a lot of
information and I don't expect it to be
friendly as far as I'm concerned
everything I've just said is a challenge
and I feel as happy as Odysseus tied to
the mast listening to the sirens
especially because I know that I can do
all this from the safety of a desk and
can call it a day whenever I feel like
it more seriously the sources we'll be
looking at in tonight's Thanet ography
our sources that consider the
assassination of Caesar to be one of the
most important questions they could deal
with these were all writers who wrote
during the Roman Empire they all knew
that the day of Caesar's assassination
marked the bloodiest final day of the
Roman Republic it was the day in which
their world changed decisively and while
none of them was prepared to say that
history would have been better if if the
Republic had continued they were all
committed to the Empire into the monarch
many of them felt that Caesar was
someone who made mistakes and that
Caesar was a man who sinned against
Roman system he's not only someone who
was sinned against so we'll see that
they were wrestling with very great
questions of political right and wrong
and justice and morality and what they
had to say about the assassination of
Caesar well turn to the sources in a
minute but first a word from our sponsor
the bard William Shakespeare I don't
know about you ladies and gentlemen but
I wouldn't be here tonight talking about
this subject if not for the very patient
teacher who suffered me as I read Julius
Caesar in junior high school it was a
wonderful moment and a superb play and
Shakespeare is remarkably faithful to
the history that he read in Plutarch who
was his major source but not remarkably
faithful to what really happened and so
one of the things that we need to do
when thinking about the source is to
remember that there's always a shadow
from Shakespeare that falls across us a
wonderful shadow an inspired shadow but
a shadow nonetheless
but even if Shakespeare didn't exist and
even if the other problems I mentioned
weren't problems we had to contend with
the simple reality of the event would
pose a grave dilemma Caesar was not
assassinated in a public place in front
of the large in front of an enormous
crowd of Romans he was assassinated at a
meeting of the Roman Senate and here is
the Roman Senate house in front of
probably two to three hundred people it
all happened very quickly
the assassins surrounded him they formed
a security perimeter while this was
happening many of the Senators were busy
looking out the windows gossiping with
their friends dozing off before they
knew what it was over and then they went
running out of the Senate house
terrified wondering if they were going
to be next what did this all pretend
nobody was there with a smartphone
videotaping the scene and from the word
go
there was a debate a controversy over
precisely what had happened who had done
it how had they killed Caesar did he
fight back and everyone was telling a
different story now to add to the
confusion Caesar was not assassinated in
the regular meeting place of the Roman
Senate many of you have been to Rome and
you've seen the Senate house this is a
rebuilding of the Senate house that sees
it that existed in Caesars day was
rebuilt in Late Antiquity later turned
into a church which is why it survives
today and probably rebuilt on precisely
the same dimensions that it had in
Caesars time but it was not used then it
was being rebuilt by Caesar Caesar was
rebranding many of the major political
sites in Rome with his name and he was
modestly going to call the Senate the
Caesar Senate house if you will the
Julian Senate House I could make a
terrible political joke but I will
restrain myself for mentioning another
great builder who likes to rename things
anyhow the Senate did not meet there
that day because it was in the process
of being rebuilt
instead it met in another place named
for another famous Roman it met in the
Senate house of Pompey Pompey Caesars
rival could now passed from the scene
had built his own Senate house a few
years earlier the Senate HUS that you
can see in Rome today is located here on
the edge of the Roman Forum but the
Senate met on the Ides of March in 44 BC
here in the Campus Martius the field of
Mars outside of the formal boundary of
the city of Rome and they met in an
architectural wonder though perhaps the
largest structure that had ever been
built in Rome it was a combination of
theater and shopping mall and public
park the Porticus theater Porticus
complex of Pompey sometimes known as
Pompey's works the western part of it
consisted of Rome's first stone
Theatre to the east stretched a series
of shops and offices in the center was a
park and at the very eastern end was the
small Senate house that Pompey had built
that bore his name and contained his
statue that's where the Senate met on
March 15th 44 BC you may be wondering
gosh I don't remember seeing that when I
went to Rome and the reason is that it
no longer exists it was much of the
stonework was mind for later buildings
and taken away but the streets of later
Rome were built on its footprint so if
you go to the old city of Rome let's see
if I can do this
I'm not sure that I can but the next
slide will help you can trace can kinda
trace the outline of the theater and
portico of Pompey so here we have it
better as you can see here here we are
in the Renaissance City and you can see
the outline of it this is wrong imagine
that it ends over here to the east and
now we're going to look closely at this
very eastern end where the Senate house
existed in 44 BC and we're gonna go to
the west of these temples we want to
look at a number letter F here this is
on the dimensions of Pompey Senate house
standing here looking westward you can
see it here and if you look at this
slide this is from a different angle the
same place where this cat is royally
sitting perhaps where the tree now grows
this is precisely where Julius Caesar
was assassinated on the Ides of March
here you see a reconstruction of what
Pompey senate-house would have looked
like and at the eastern end there is the
podium where Caesar was sitting on that
fateful day as I said people left the
Senate meeting and everybody told a
different story now one cause for
optimism about the sources one of the
people in attendance that day was none
other than the most famous one of the
most famous writers of the ancient world
one of the great as the silver-tongued
orator one of the greatest politicians a
brilliant philosopher a man never at a
loss for words I'm referring to Cicero
who you see here in this print by
William Blake
Cicero was at the Senate meeting and
just a few weeks afterwards perhaps a
month or two he writes about what
happened it's one of his works called on
divination and in on divination he
briefly recounts the scene
let me quote in that Senate the greater
part of which he had chosen in Pompey
Senate house in front of the statue of
Pompey himself with so many of his
Centurions watching that he was to lie
there slaughtered by the most noble of
the citizens some of whom he had
furnished with everything they had and
not only would none of his friends
approach his body but not even any of
his slaves now there's a lot of truth in
this we know from many sources that
Caesar really was slaughtered in front
of Pompey statue and we know that many
if not most of the conspirators were not
his enemies they were his friends
conspiracy consisted of 60-plus men if
we believe a later source most of them
were his friends we know that many of
the leading conspirators were his
friends to know Caesar was not
necessarily to love him to know him was
to know that he was somebody who really
did want to become in effect if not in
name the king of Rome we know that there
was at least one of his Centurions
present there that day we know that many
not most of the Senators his sister said
but many of the Senators perhaps a third
had been chosen by Caesar himself we
know that his body was left there it's
not true however that his body was left
there and that not even his slaves would
approach it three of his slaves picked
up Caesars corpse and they loaded it
onto the litter but he had been brought
to the Senate house in and they carried
him home but because there are only
three slaves you need four to carry a
litter litter Tilted and we're told that
caesar's
pathetically lay hanging outside the
litter if he was carried home about half
mile to his house so Cicero is giving us
a relatively if not completely accurate
portrait of what happened that day but
it's very brief we want more from Cicero
especially because he writes many
letters during this period and then
about nine months later actually seven
months later he starts giving us famous
series of speeches political speeches
called the philippics fiery orations
about Roman politics in this period but
Cicero is everywhere and nowhere when it
comes to the accounts of Caesar's
assassination this is a bust now in the
Vatican of Cicero it's so frustrating
because so often in this period he gives
us luscious details of events for
instance December 18th 45 BC just a few
months before the assassination Caesar
in a small entourage 2,000 soldiers
descended on Cicero's estate on the Bay
of Naples and Cicero pulls the stops out
in describing that event in detail down
to Caesars personal toilette but sadly
not so for the Ides of March she's more
discrete so we need to turn to other
sources now the good news is that there
were other contemporaries who wrote
about this
I didn't plan this to recreate the mood
in the Senate that day for my next trick
so what we were saying is that there are
a number of contemporary sources for the
assassination one of them was a
historian named asinus Pauli oh don't
worry there won't be a quiz and he wrote
a highly regarded history of Rome from
60 to 44 BC then there was the historian
Livy who was 15 years old at the time of
the assassination he lived in northern
Italy but he came South to Rome to
complete his education if he wasn't
there in 44 BC he was there shortly
afterwards and he wrote about the
assassination of the career of Julius
Caesar including his assassination and
there was strable the great geographer
he was 18 years old at the time
a native of Asia Minor came to Augustus
Rome and also wrote about the
assassination of Julius Caesar and then
there were the memoirist Caesars
right-hand man obvious wrote a memoir
Brutus's stepson byblos wrote a memoir
and Brutus is friend embolus
wrote a book only specializing on this
death of Julius Caesar if only we could
read these books but you guessed that
none of them exists all gone fortunately
they were used by later writers who do
toss us a bone or two about the
assassination a man named Phileas
particular a soldier statesman who lived
during the reign of the emperor Tiberius
so fifty to seventy years after the
assassination wrote a good history of
Rome or a man named Flores who lived
another fifty years or so after that
also wrote a very useful history of Rome
with very brief references to the
assassination but that's not my main
focus this evening my main focus is five
ancient texts that really are art they
provide the only detailed accounts of
the assassination that survived far more
information than we get about sis then
we get from Cicero one of these texts
was written by someone who was 20 at the
time of Caesars assassination he wasn't
in Rome but he ended up in
and we'll talk more about him in a
moment so his account is more or less
contemporary the others were written Oh
between a hundred and two hundred and
twenty-five years after the
assassination of Caesar so they're quite
a bit later and they're looking back at
the assassination of Caesar at the plus
side on the plus side all of these five
authors were to some extent or other men
who led public lives they were statesmen
only one of them could really be called
an academic and even he had some public
experience so they knew where of they
spoke oddly four of the five authors
wrote in Greek only one of them wrote in
Latin the Roman Empire was always a
bilingual operation and the Greeks
punched above their weight quite a bit
of the literature of the Roman Empire's
in Greek rather than Latin but the most
important caveat to have in mind is as I
said none of these authors was trying to
be objective each of them was trying to
looked at the assassination of Julius
Caesar as an important moral and
political point something that said
something about the world they lived in
the Empire they lived in the system of
government they lived in and something
about the nature of greatness they
thought there are questions of justice
and right and wrong as to were the
assassins right was Caesar wrong what is
one to make of this
so as historians we don't so much read
these texts as wrestle with them and let
me now introduce you to them so the
first one is a man named Nicholas of
Damascus perhaps the greatest ancient
author who bet that most of us have
never heard of Nicholas was a Greek
speaker who came from Damascus Syria
he studied Aristotle and Thucydides when
he was young he was a serious student of
philosophy in history and wrote
philosophy in history and the reason
he's important for our purposes is he
wrote a book called the life of Augustus
the life of the Emperor Augustus most of
it is lost only a small portion of it
survives in fact technically none of it
survives all we have is a summary
it a Reader's Digest version that comes
from a later period luckily for us it
focuses on the the youth of the Emperor
Augustus and the assassination of Julius
Caesar in the aftermath of the
assassination now as I said Nicholas was
a very serious student of philosophy in
history and he approaches it in a rather
impressive manner he gives us an
antidote to the version we get in
Shakespeare which is it shows an
assassination led by a very idealistic
Brutus this Nicholas gives us a very
Buber realistic a very skeptical account
of the assassins and what they were
doing and he makes this a struggle over
power over a political power not over
right and wrong he makes Caesar
something of an innocent victim part of
the reason for this is that later in his
life
Nicholas actually was employed by the
Emperor Augustus Augustus as many of you
know was Julius Caesar's grand nephew he
was the grandson of ceaser sister as a
young man his name was Gaius Octavius
and we tend to refer to him as Octavian
when he was young he was adopted by
Caesar when Caesar died in his will was
read young Gaius Octavius was adopted
he became the heir of most of Caesars
fortune he takes the name Caesar and
eventually after a long civil war
emerges as Rome's first emperor
naturally he had a dog in this fight and
he was on the side of Caesar and against
the assassins to add to the degree to
which Nicolas account is colored by
Augustus Nicolas clearly got some of his
information from a book that Augustus
himself wrote his memoirs de WETA sua by
the Emperor Augustus you might be
thinking gosh I don't remember ever
reading that and you haven't because it
no longer exists we have about 18 short
quotations from it and that's all it's a
great pity was probably four hundred and
fifty pages long so a substantial book
and it's a book in which Augustus gives
us his version of his life and how he
rose to
power it was supposed to be tell-all
autobiography in which he gave you an
insider's personal view of his rise to
power I'm tempted to quote the line that
Pamela Smith Hill gave us this afternoon
not a word of it is true
not even the ands or the buzz we can be
sure that there was more propaganda than
truth in the Emperor Augustus ha's
memoirs but before we discard Nikolas to
things in his favor
Nikolas by the time he came to write
this book had had a remarkable political
education as I told you he ends up in
life becoming an advisor and assistant a
secretary to the Emperor Augustus but
earlier in life he had two other jobs
that would give someone an extraordinary
education in the world of conspiracy and
high politics his first job was working
for King Herod yes that King Herod the
massacre of the innocents a man who is
revolved as a tyrant in both Christian
and Jewish tradition anyone who worked
at that Court and survived knew
something about politics but as if that
wasn't enough nicholas of damascus had
another job as tutor to the children of
Antony and Cleopatra yes that Antony and
Cleopatra
this is Cleopatra it's a bust in Berlin
in the background that's not Antony that
Caesar who was her lover before Antony
see me after class if you have any
questions about that so Nicholas is a
work that I assure you is worth reading
the second source and the one who is the
anti Nicholas in a way is Plutarch
Plutarch Millett of his life in a small
town in central Greece about two hours
drive north of Athens today a place
called Kyra Nia a very small place you'd
hardly even notice it if you pass
through probably a bigger place in
Plutarch's day but not much of a town he
was a man who is immensely knowledgeable
and learner
and a had a great literary outpour and
probably produced no fewer than 250
works many of which still exist today he
had studied with a philosopher in
Alexandria a great intellectual center
he'd been to Rome in Italy several times
he was intimately involved with Greek
religion in the Oracle at Delphi and he
was very well-connected became a Roman
citizen late in life is made the
honorary governor of Greece so he's a
man who knew a lot about politics even
though his main activity was being a
teacher and running a small classical
academy if you will in Cairo Nia where
he had a substantial number of pupils
his most famous book is his parallel
lives the parallel lives of the noble
Greeks and Romans these are not so much
biographies as brilliant essays about
ethics philosophy and politics he's
interested in the people he writes about
for moral reasons for what they tell us
about human nature and human psychology
and justice nonetheless luckily for us
he was a very honest historian he went
to great effort to get the facts right
he wasn't much interested in chronology
so he's not real good for what happened
when and he compresses timelines and the
speeches as often in ancient history are
fiction but the rest of the details are
carefully done and he often cites his
sources the most important of his lies
for our purposes is the life of Caesar
second most important is a life of
Brutus then a life of Mark Antony and
finally a life of Cicero and for
Plutarch the philosopher and the Greek
his hero is Brutus Marcus Brutus was a
philosopher as well as being a statesman
and a soldier and Marcus Brutus was a
philhellene
who spoke Greek well and was well versed
in Greek philosophy and Brutus get that
Plutarch gives us a version in which
blue Brutus is a good man a heroic man
who tries to save the Republic and
who fails oops okay the third version
and Plutarch is writing by the way about
100 AD so about a hundred and fifty
years after the assassination a few
decades later let us say in the 120 ad
we get suet oniy Asst Suetonius
well-known as the author of the lies of
the twelve Caesars and this is a
medieval woodcut of him Suetonius was a
man who rose in Roman public service a
very high office under the Emperor
Hadrian the equivalent of a cabinet
secretary he was in charge of imperial
correspondence a major way in which
people of importance in the Roman Empire
dealt with the central government and
had their questions answered by the
central government he loses his job in a
palace coup having to do with a scandal
it gives him more time to write he
devotes the rest of his life to writing
a series of books the lives of the
twelve Caesars is one of them his view
of the Emperor he begins with Julius and
he ends with Domitian who died in 1918
96 so before his lifetime he sees Rome
as on a slow decline from the noble days
of the Republic through the corruption
of the Empire CC Caesar as a great
general but a very poor politician and a
terrible human being and so in some
sense sua toniest thinks that Caesar had
it coming to him in his assassination
the next source is a peon of Alexandria
a peon lived around the same time as
Suetonius except he was a Greek speaker
he came from Alexandria Egypt he has a
career in Roman public life he is a
governor of several provinces and goes
to Rome and I'm sorry he's not a
governor but he has a high official in
the administration in Egypt he goes to
Rome and he serves as an attorney
essentially the equivalent of an
attorney today who would argue before
the Supreme Court he's an attorney who
argues before the Emperor and he also
writes a universal history of very
popular genre and antiquity and
encyclopedia in which much of which
there is cribbed from earlier authors he
writes a history of Rome a very
important source for us today because
his five books on the civil wars that
destroyed the Republic from the rack Ida
Caesar are our single most detailed
account we have of this period so
tremendously important he greatly
respected Caesar especially as a soldier
and doesn't have very many nice things
to say about the men who killed him and
finally the history of geocaches also
known as Cassius do either one is okay
he lived quite a bit later around 200 AD
and even later he finishes his history
around 230 AD so we're well well well
beyond the assassination of Caesar he
was a Roman senator a very learned man
who had read widely but it's clear that
when he sat down to write he sat down to
write a little bit like a jazz musician
doing a riff he remembers some of the
notes and the rest he makes up he didn't
have many kind things to say about the
assassin about the assassins a great
believer in the Roman monarchy but it's
a good read so that's what we've got
folks as I said a modern historian would
be tearing his hair out at this sort of
event but for a classicist it's pure joy
to have to work through sources like
this and to try to piece together what
really happened just to give you a taste
of it let me refer to one brief event
probably the most famous single
quotation from the assassination of
Julius Caesar the famous line that
Caesar uttered when he saw that the
assassins included a man who he trusted
a man whom he had pardoned for his sins
against him treated as his friend the
famous moment when Caesar turns to
Brutus and says at tu brute a then fall
Caesar a great moment in Shakespeare but
it never happened
Caesar never said at tu brute a this was
invented in the Renaissance by
Shakespeare and other writers what did
Caesar say well let's turn to the five
sources
Nicholas Damascus gives us no
information on what Caesar says nothing
whatsoever Appian says that Caesar
responded to the assassins who waylay
him ambush him in the Senate House he
responded with anger and shouts sue
atonia says he wasn't able to say
anything Plutarch and do agrees he
wasn't able to say anything Plutarch
says that when Publius Servilius Casca
the first man to strike Caesar Caesar
said impious Casca this is violence and
on another and another one of his books
Plutarch says that Caesar said a curse
it Casca this is violence close enough
the same thing what about ektu birthday
well sue atonia sind die o Cassius say
there are a lot of rumors about what
went down on the Senate house that day
and there are scurrilous writers who
claim that Caesar did say something but
don't believe it it wasn't true well
what was it they say that Caesar said
they say that Caesar said in Greek not
in Latin he said Chi su teknon Kai su
teknon it means you too child and they
say he said it too Brutus what did he
mean by this if he said it and of course
as I just said
Suetonius and deal Cassius said but he
didn't say it but what did he mean we
all want to know the scholars say it
could have three meanings the first was
that he was quoting a line from Greek
tragedy that went on to say you too
child shall someday have sufferings such
as mine the second is that he was
referencing a very familiar line in a
cursed tablet Greeks and Romans took
curses very seriously
they had formal cursed tablets which
they buried in the earth and they used
against their enemies and the cursed
tablets often said same to you you can
interpret it more salty if you like in
Greek that's chi-su and here is a mosaic
of a cursed tablet and you can see the
guy saying chi-su the final explanation
of what Caesar might have
by this as far as I know this was
invented by the playwright George
Bernard Shaw in his preface to Caesar
and Cleopatra he says look everybody
knew that si Caesar was a great ladies
man and everybody knew that one of his
mistresses well let me take a step back
his mistress in 44 BC or perhaps his
mistress - one was none other than
Cleopatra queen of Egypt a Cleopatra
claimed that her but Caesar was the
father of her illegitimate son whose
name was Ptolemy the 15th but whose
nickname was Little Caesar Kazarian
little known fact was that Cleopatra was
actually in Rome that day on the Ides of
March Caesar had ensconced her in his
villa on the other side of the Tiber in
the hills outside of the city but
Caesars she was Caesars most famous
mistress but his most famous Roman
mistress was none other than Brutus's
mother
Servilia and there had been you need a
scorecard folks to keep score of this
they had been a rumour that Brutus was
Caesar's illegitimate son and it always
been denied I'll spare you some of the
complications so George Bernard Shaw
says why did Caesar turn to Brutus and
say you too child because in his dying
breath he wanted to get out of zinger
and the singer was him saying - Brutus
guess what you really are my son I
really am your father
you have just murdered your father
according to Roman law that is the most
heinous crime a Roman could ever do have
a nice day personally I find a little
hard to believe that Caesar could have
been that self composed to do that but
as you see the authors really disagree
about what was said and our job as
historians is to exercise judgment and
to make sense of it I want to turn now
in the remaining time to look at two
other sources about Caesars funeral
neither of them as literary one of them
is an event and the other is an object
the event of course no longer exists and
our reports of it are inconclusive
though archaeological evidence for once
is rather helpful and then we'll turn to
the object the event is the funeral of
Julius Caesar
you know this from Shakespeare the
famous friends Romans countrymen speech
when Mark Antony gets on the podium
besides Caesars corpse and he riles the
crowd up by calling the conspirators
honorable men and the result is a riot
the tears room apart and drives the
conspirators out of the city of Rome
couple of problems with this Antony
never said friends Romans countrymen and
never said an honourable man those are
invented by Shakespeare Antony was the
master of ceremonies at Caesars funeral
and as we'll see in a moment he does
some remarkable things the sources
disagree mightily as to whether he
actually gave a funeral speech or simply
let read out a list of Caesars honours I
believe he did give a funeral speech
talking a moment about what else he did
it's also important to recognize that
the funeral was not quite the turning
point that Shakespeare makes it out to
be and I won't take time now to explain
but if you'd like in the qat I can tell
you why it wasn't quite the turning
point that Shakespeare makes it have to
be the important thing about the funeral
is the remark to remarkable things that
Mark Antony does and the real Mark
Antony didn't look like Marlon Brando
I'm afraid this is the real Mark Antony
tough guy but no Brando Caesar did have
a public funeral it took place about
five days after the Ides of March
probably on the 20th of March 44 BC the
funeral took place in the Roman Forum
which is here in the foreground and
Caesars body was brought out in a
procession a formal procession it was
brought out to the speaker's platform by
the way Caesar had torn down the old
speaker's platform and built a new
speaker's platform which he modestly
called Caesar speakers platform really
and the body was brought there as was
the custom and the funeral of a great
Met person in Rome
it was followed by an actor wearing a
wat a wax mask a piece wax masked that
had made been made during Caesars
lifetime to look like Caesar he wore
clothes like Caesar and he had practice
walking like Caesar so of course this
would make a big impression on the crowd
there'd be other actors wearing last
beeswax masks of Caesars famous
ancestors and he was accompanied by his
soldiers to the sound of music and
wailing I want you to imagine thousands
and thousands and thousands of people
packed into the Roman Forum a true mob
scene the corpses brought up covered to
the podium and this is Caesars rostra
this is all that is mortal of it here is
another view of it it would have there
would have been a platform here and it's
facing the Roman Forum imagine this arch
out of the way imagine most of these
structures out of the way so an open
area thousands of people and there
stands Antony in addition to the stent
giving some sort of funeral address he
does two other things first of all
instead of having the usual custom where
there are is a professional chorus of
mourners who lead the wailing he leads
the audience and kind of a football
stadium cheer saying things like Caesar
didn't deserve it did he and they'd say
no he didn't deserve it Caesar was a
great man wasn't he Oh Caesar was a
great man
back and forth back and forth an
audience participation things such as it
never been seen before and finally the
piece de resistance
he brings out a wax model of Caesars
body on a pulley rotating that shows all
of Caesars wounds including the wounds
on his face and you can be sure that
whether Caesar was wounded on the back
or not they showed him wounded in the
back in fact I suspect that the number
of wounds that appears in most of our
sources twenty-three wounds comes
precisely from this event remember very
very few people in Rome had actually
seen it happen and their accounts
disagreed there was no official public
version of what had happened
and Anthony is using this occasion to
give the Roman people his version of the
event he rises up the crowd perhaps with
the help of a Jean provocateur brought
there by ant planted there by Antony the
crowd now riots they go up to the podium
they take Caesars corpse they try to
break in up they try to go up the
Capitoline Hill and to break into the
temporal temple of Jupiter to burn it
there but the priests with some help
from soldiers no doubt stopped them from
doing that they don't want to go off to
the field of Mars a half mile away where
a funeral pyre has been prepared they
take the corpse to the other end of the
forum to this site here and they build a
makeshift funeral pyre they get wooden
hot wooden benches from the nearby law
law courts and they cremate Caesars body
how do we know exactly where it was
because Augustus later on built a temple
the temple of the God Julius Caesar on
precisely the site and mark the spot
where Caesar was assassinated and even
today people in Rome leave offerings for
the ghosts of Julius Caesar the
information we have about this event is
precious it's contested the authors
disagree as I say some of them say he
didn't even give a funeral oration
Cicero says he does and that's good
enough for me
all that we know that we can be sure of
us this was an unprecedented act that
Antony carried out and that swayed the
crowds in Rome and the time let me just
turn to the last event that I want to
talk about the last item that I want to
talk about not an event but an object it
was created two years after the Ides of
March so 42 BC it is a coin probably the
most famous coin of the ancient world
and it's called the Ides of March coin
because as you can see it says on it
Ides of March in Latin it was issued by
Brutus and Cassius to their soldiers
Brutus and Cassius the two leading
conspirators had fled to the east they'd
raised an army and they'd raised an army
of about fifty thousand men to fight
against Mark Antony
and Caesar's heir Octavian and the
showdown in northern Greece in 42 BC
they had to pay the soldiers so they
taxed and looted cities up and down the
Roman East to come up with enough coin
to pay these soldiers a really enormous
amount of money and they issued a number
of coins to commemorate the occasion in
the ancient world coins were important
sources of propaganda and as I said the
most famous of these coins is the Ides
of March coin on the reverse is this
image which you see we'll come back to
it in a moment
on the obverse is this image of Brutus
it's a picture of Brutus can't see it
very well in this one but he's wearing a
beard is a symbol of mourning for the
Republic and it's got his name Brutus
Imperator Brutus the victorious general
and here is the name of the mint master
Lucius Claudius caecus dias not a
tremendously important person now this
symbol of Brutus was in a remarkable
statement
the reason it's a remarkable statement
was that just a few years before julius
caesar had issued a coin in which he
proclaimed himself to be kaiser
Imperator caesar the victorious general
a coin that was the first coin in the
entire history of rome to show a met
living man on the coin the roman
republic had always considered it
uncivil to show a living person on a
coin against the spirit of Roman
republicanism against the spirit of
democracy to make any one living
individual almost like a king on a coin
Caesar had broken that tradition by this
coin and you can see he's also wearing a
triumphal reed wreath making it even
worse and he's got the symbol of his
position as the chief priest as Rome
which he also was by the way the
triumphal wreath is also there to hide
his baldness Caesar I was very vain
about being bald and Brutus therefore by
depicting himself on the coin and by
calling himself Imperator calls into
question his idealism
if he was such an idealist why does he
depict himself on a coin is he trying to
create a cult of personality like Caesar
could it be that one of Brutus's motives
one of the reasons he assassinated
Caesar is not that Caesar was so
powerful but that the power was going to
the wrong man to Caesar rather than
Brutus
that's what Nicholas of Damascus argues
but that of course is only one side of
the coin let's look at the other side of
the coin this is one of the few Gold
versions of this coin most of them are
silver denarii silver pennies what you
can see on this coin is in the center of
the coin there is a cap that a freed
slave wore this is a cap when a slave
was freed and in Rome it was much easier
for a slave to be freed than in the Old
South when a slave was freed he wore a
freed man's cap it's a sign that the
Ides of March was meant to be the day of
liberation of Rome from dictatorship but
the other symbol very prominently there
are the daggers the two daggers
symbolizing the daggers that were used
to kill Julius Caesar if you look
closely whoops did it again if you look
closely you will see that the daggers
are not the daggers are not the same the
dagger on the left is a craw has a cross
shaped hilt the dagger on the right has
two discs on the hilt well talk in a
minute about why the daggers have
different why did a group two daggers
were different the first thing to notice
though is that they are daggers and a
dagger was not a dagger was not a dagger
in Rome there are different kinds of
daggers these are specifically what the
Romans called a Puccio a military dagger
oops
no here yes here is a modern recreation
of a poogie oh this is in the Archaea
Park in a lacy of the site of Caesars
last paddling in Gaul and modern France
and as you can see it resembles the
dagger on the Ides of March coin
Mark Antony in his speeches against the
conspirators said that they didn't use
military daggers they killed Caesar with
a switchblade the Roman version of a
switchblade is a Sica it's a kind of
dagger that's used by thieves by
assassins by hitmen in Italian and
Spanish the word for hitman today is
Sicario in fact there's a movie recent
movie Sicario about a hitman
Antony says they were hitmen they used
caecus just going backwards
okay here's a seka cicero gives a speech
in which responds and says they weren't
hitmen they didn't use sikhae they were
in Sakaki so the kind of weapon that the
kana that they used is important but
putting the Pujo on the coin Brutus is
saying to his soldiers we did an
honorable job we did an our civic duty
in killing Caesar We Were Soldiers Roman
soldiers like you doing our duty and you
should you do your duty but why do the
two daggers have different hills I think
there are two that reasons for this one
is they're saying to soldiers we know
war we know weapons we know very
seriously the difference between a
dagger with a cross-shaped hilt and a
dagger with a by disco disco
just by discoid I'll help the other
thing is I suspect that these daggers
are meant to represent Brutus and
Cassius but the one dagger is Brutus ISM
one is Cassius I suspect that the cross
shaped dagger is Brutus's because
they're very rare in the archaeological
record
very rarely do we find these daggers in
the archaeological record a cross shaped
dagger so I think that's why it was
bruised so this coin
it's a remarkable corner I do just want
to tell you that Cassius Dio mentions
this coin in his writing it's one of the
only coins in the ancient world that
anyone comments ancient writer comments
on and he says it specifically meant to
symbolize liberation and the Freedmen's
cap
was a symbol of Liberty well it didn't
work for the soldiers that go on to
fight antony and octavian at the Battle
of Philippi in November of October in
November of 42 their defeated Brutus and
Cassius commit suicide and that's it for
the defenders of the Roman Republic so
let me sum up what can we get from the
ancient sources how trustworthy are the
ancient sources for Caesar's
assassination for the dictator Gaius
Julius Caesar in this renaissance statue
they don't give us the degree of
certainty that they would like they are
in a way an opening an invitation an
invitation to study the classics an
invitation to go back and to read them
on our own and to sift them to weigh
them to use the skills that a classical
education can give us skills that not
only teach us how to read text but
skills that force us to ask questions
about justice about statesmanship about
morality and about greatness the sources
from the point of view of just the facts
are not trustworthy at all but because
the sources the ancient force sources
force us to walk with the greats they
are trustworthy indeed thank you